[Applause]
out in front and she knew it
this the moment liz truss has fought so
hard for
look at her smile as opponent rishi
sunak hung his head now the result their
body language telling us all we needed
to know rishi sunak 60
399
liz truss 81
326.
therefore i give notice that liz truss
is elected as the leader of the
conservative and unionist party
a brutal campaign concluded miss truss's
husband handed her the victory speech
but no handshake for her opponent as she
took to the stage and paid tribute to
her predecessor instead
boris you got brexit done
you crushed jeremy corbyn
you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to vladimir putin
you were admired from kiev to carlyle
awkward applause from a divided party
far from healed but little time to
linger on the past as liz trust spoke of
the mammoth task ahead
we need to show that we will deliver
over the next two years
i will deliver a bold plan to cut taxes
and grow our economy
i will deliver on the energy crisis
dealing with people's energy bills but
also dealing with the long-term issues
we have on energy supply
long-term problems but solutions needed
right now
it was by no means a landslide but liz
truss has been elected the leader of the
conservative party will be our next
prime minister there will be euphoria in
the room and within her team but soon
she will face the hard reality of the
spiraling energy crisis plus huge
inflation and the prospect of a
protracted long recession she ends his
founding streak as a prime minister with
the hardest entry in over four decades
and one which will demand a united party
she didn't do as well as boris johnson
in 2019 did she do you think it reflects
the divisions in the party i mean what
do you make of the result a little bit
disappointed no it's a good result i
look i think it's not not hugely
different than percentage terms too
roughly where boris was last time party
needs to come out together we are a big
wide tent again it's one of the
strengths of our party i'm sure one of
the things that
our new leader will be working on but
the leaders audience no longer just the
people in this room the entire country
now watching and waiting for liz truss's
energy support package expect it to be
big and bold i expect it to be big and
bold that is her style
but she's not a reckless individual she
will be cautious she'll be thinking
about the sequencing of all of the
economic
policies that she wants to to bring in
and she'll build the right team around
her
a mistrust left no time to waste
arriving at conservative hq less than an
hour after her win a lot to decide and
do in a short space of time political
pressure now acute we want an energy
freeze it's vital for families and
households across the country so i want
to see that happen
there's no justification for an incoming
prime minister not doing it because the
political will is there across the
political parties the question now will
be who's going to pay for it leaving
conservative hq this afternoon it's
pressure this new pm won't be able to
wave away
now just hours until she heads here
tonight boris johnson's cabinet emptying
as resignations continued
tomorrow a new pm and
cabinet but the problems they inherit
familia and how liz trust responds will
set the tone of her premiership for good
or ill beth rigby sky news westminster